(crowd yelling)
- People! People please!
I know you're all upset.
As you all know, at 6:15
PM yesterday evening,
a train derailed and hit a
man named Jamaal Crenshaw,
killing him instantly.
Now, I know that safety is
your number one concern,
which is why we decided
to temporarily suspend train
432 from operational status.
(crowd yelling)
- This is outrageous!
- I don't know about y'all,
but the way I was raised
if you don't wanna
get hit by a train,
don't take the steps
to get hit by a train.
- What?
- I stand near the
tracks all the time
and trains never
fly off and hit me.
- It's interesting you
should bring that up,
because a study
was just conducted
that said people like
Jamaal are approximately,
let me get this number right,
one billion times
more likely to get hit
by a malfunctioning train
than someone like you.
- We don't want data!
We want answers!
- Look, we have a video
of it hitting the man.
- We don't know what happened
before that video started.
(crowd agreeing)
- We are suspending the
train, and that is final!
An innocent man was killed!
- Innocent, huh?
Well I don't believe he's
so innocent, after all!
Age 19:
Jaywalkin'!
(crowd gasps)
Age 22: Litterin'!
Age 23: Jaywalkin' again!
(crowd yells)
Mr. Man, this man is
possessed by the devil!
- Are you saying that
this man deserved
to get hit by a train
because he committed
a few misdemeanors?
- You hate trains!
(crowd yells in agreement)
- No I don't! I
don't hate trains!
Look. Ignoring the fact
is not helping anyone
in this situation.
We need to learn
from the situation.
Y'know, work together,
and move forward.
If we can institute
some sort of policy
make some changes,
then maybe, just maybe,
less black people will be shot
by the police for no reason!
- Who's getting shot?
- Big city, smart lookin'...
- Nevermind.